>> Laura: WHILE SOME GOVERNORS
ARE USING THE COVID CRISIS TO
GRAB MORE POWER AND UNDERMINE
THEIR CITIZENS CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS, MY NEXT GUEST IS AMONG
THOSE TRYING TO PRESERVE LIBERTY
WHILE ALSO SAVING LIVES AND IS
TAKING ON OFFICIALS IN HIS OWN
STATE TO DO IT.
GEORGIA GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP IS
SUING THE CITY OF ATLANTA FOR
MANDATING MASKS BUT MAINLY FOR
GOING BACK INTO LOCKDOWN.
THIS MORNING, ATLANTA’S MAYOR
RESPONDS.
>> IT IS MIND-BOGGLING THAT THIS
GOVERNOR WASTES RESOURCES ON
SUING ME PERSONALLY FOR MASK
MANDATES AND VOLUNTARY BUSINESS
RECOMMENDATIONS AND GUIDELINES.
IT IS VERY CLEAR THAT HE IS
PUTTING POLITICS OVER PEOPLE, IT
IS A DISTRACTION FROM WHAT THE
REAL ENEMY IS.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR KEMP JOINS
ME NOW, IT’S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE TO THE
MAYOR?
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHAT’S REALLY
GOING ON IN GEORGIA.
I’M WORKING VERY HARD EVERY DAY
AND HAVE BEEN FOR A LONG TIME
NOW TO PROTECT THE LIVES AS WELL
AS THE LIVELIHOODS OF MY FELLOW
CITIZENS.
HOWEVER, WE HAVE LOCAL MAYORS
WHO ARE PLAYING POLITICS, THEY
WANT TO GO BACK TO SHELTER IN
PLACE, THEY WANT TO STOP IN
PERSON DINING, PULLING THE RUG
OUT FROM UNDER PEOPLE AND I’M
NOT GOING TO ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN.
WE ARE FIGHTING TWO BATTLES HERE
NOW, ONE TO PROTECT LIVES BUT
ALSO TO PROTECT LIVELIHOODS AND
SO I FILED A LAWSUIT TO STOP
THEM BECAUSE THOSE ORDERS ARE IN
CONFLICT WITH THE STATEWIDE
ORDER THAT I HAVE EXECUTED.
>> Laura: THERE ARE THOSE WHO
WOULD SAY IF THE MASKS HELP IN
10% OF THE CASES, THEN WHY ISN’T
THAT GOOD ENOUGH TO SAY -- YOU
CAN SAVE SOME LIVES, MAYBE THEY
AREN’T 100%, ISN’T THAT WORTH
THIS ONGOING MASK MANDATES AND
SOME OF THESE MAYORS HAVE IN
PLACE?
>> I THINK A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY
ON THAT.
I’M STILL FOLLOWING THE HEALTH
ADVICE THAT FORTY-YEAR
EPIDEMIOLOGIST, HARVARD
EDUCATED, GREAT PERSON, AS MUCH
EXPERIENCE AS ANYBODY IN THE
COUNTRY -- I DON’T FEEL LIKE A
MANDATE IS NEEDED FOR GEORGIANS
TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
WE HAVE EXISTING ORDERS ON THE
BOOKS AND THIS IS WHAT IS
FRUSTRATING ABOUT A LOT OF THE
LOCALS WERE PLAYING POLITICS
WITH THAT SPIRIT WE HAVE ORDERS
ON THE BOOKS THAT HAVE WORKED IN
THE PAST THAT HELPED US FLATTEN
THE CURVE AND STOP THE SPREAD.
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY THROUGH MY
ORDER TO USE THEIR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ENFORCE THOSE
ORDERS AND THEY ARE NOT DOING
THAT.
INSTEAD OF HAVING A GOVERNMENT
MANDATE, ENFORCE THE ORDERS THAT
WE HAVE, MAKE SURE BUSINESSES
ARE FOLLOWING THE RULES, PEOPLE
ARE SOCIALLY DISTANCING, I’VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
WEARING A MASK AS MUCH AS
ANYBODY.
FOR THOSE WHO DO NOT WANT TO
WEAR A MASK IF YOU HAVE A HEALTH
CONDITION THAT PREVENTS IT OR
SOME SORT OF PHOBIA OR ANYTHING,
JUST SOCIALLY DISTANCE YOURSELF.
IF EVERYBODY DOES THEIR PART,
WE’LL FLATTEN THE CURVE AGAIN,
STOP THE SPREAD AND CONTINUE TO
REOPEN OUR ECONOMY.
IT’S IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THAT,
WE LITERALLY HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK,
BARELY GETTING BY IN THIS
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT -- THE
AMOUNT OF MORTGAGES NOT BEING
PAID ON TIME IS GOING UP AND WE
ARE LOOKING AT LARGE COMPANIES
LIKE DELTA AIR LINES AND OTHERS,
IN THE FUTURE IF THE ECONOMY
DOESN’T REBOUND, THEY ARE GOING
TO BE FORCED TO START LAYING
PEOPLE OFF.
WE GOT TO KEEP OUR ECONOMY UP
AND ALSO FIGHT THE VIRUS AND
PROTECT LIVES AND THAT’S WHAT
WE’RE DOING.
>> Laura: THIS IS KIND OF A
CONTROVERSIAL QUESTION, BUT DO
YOU THINK THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING ELSE GOING ON HERE
WHERE THERE IS SOME ELEMENT
WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHO
THINK A SHUTDOWN, PROBABLY WOULD
SAYSAVE LIVES, THAT WOULD PULL T
BRAKES ON A RECOVERY THAT IS
UNDERWAY BEFORE A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
I’M ASKING THAT BECAUSE THAT’S
WHAT SO MANY OF MY VIEWERS ARE
WONDERING, SAYING WAIT A SECOND,
WE KNOW THERE ARE HOT SPOTS IN
DEALING WITH THOSE BUT YOU SHUT
THIS ECONOMY DOWN AND A LOT OF
STATES -- WE’RE TOAST.
>> PEOPLE CAN’T HANDLE IT.
I WOULDN’T BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO
THEIR POLITICS, IT CERTAINLY
SEEMS LIKE THEY ARE TRYING TO
UNDERMINE OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
I’M AS CONCERNED ABOUT THE VIRUS
AS ANYBODY, WE ARE WORKING WITH
OUR LOCAL SCHOOL LEADERS AND
SCHOOL SUPERINTENDENTS TO GET
SCHOOLS OPEN.
I GOT ACCOSTED WHEN I STARTED
OPENING BUSINESSES EARLY ON BY
THE LEFT, THEY WERE MAKING FUN
OF US OPENING UP BARBERSHOPS AND
HAIR SALONS AND NOW THEY ARE
SAYING THE GUIDANCE THAT WE HAD,
HAVING PEOPLE WEAR A MASK AND
USE PPE AND HAVING THESE RULES
IN PLACE HAVE KEPT THE SPREAD
DOWN IN OUR SALONS AND
BARBERSHOPS.
IT’S GOT TO BE PANDEMIC POLITICS
BUT I KNOW THIS -- TALKING TO
OUR HOSPITAL CEOs, THEY CANNOT
GO THROUGH WHAT THEY DID BEFORE,
THEY WON’T BE NATURALLY VIABLE,
IT WILL BANKRUPT OUR HOSPITALS.
WE’VE HEARD FROM RESTAURANT
TOURS THAT ARE LIKE IF WE HAVE
TO SHUT DOWN AGAIN, IF WE HAVE
TO MOVE AWAY FROM IN PERSON
DINING, WE ARE OUT FOR GOOD.
OUR STATE CAN’T AFFORD THAT.
>> Laura: THE UNIVERSITY OF
GEORGIA, ARE THEY GOING TO BE
PLAYING FOOTBALL IN THE FALL?
>> I TOLD ALL THE YOUNG PEOPLE
INCLUDING MY DAUGHTERS, THEY’RE
DOING REALLY GOOD JOB OF
FOLLOWING GUIDANCE MOST OF THE
TIME THAT OUR YOUNG FOLKS NEED
TO WEAR A MASK IF THEY ARE GOING
OUT AND THEY CAN’T SOCIALLY
DISTANCE AND THEY’VE GOT TO
FOLLOW THE GUIDANCE IF THEY WANT
COLLEGE FOOTBALL THIS FALL.
THAT IS LIKE A RELIGION IN THE
SOUTH, I WANT TO SEE IT HAPPEN,
IT’S A HUGE ECONOMIC IMPACT BUT
WE NEEDED AS A SOCIETY RIGHT
NOW.
THAT’S WHAT I’M ASKING EVERYBODY
FOR THE NEXT FOUR WEEKS, WEAR A
MASK.
A SOCIALLY DISTANCE, WASH YOUR
HANDS AND FOLLOW THE EXISTING
GUIDANCE THAT WE HAVE, IT WILL
WORK.
>> Laura: GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT, THANKS FOR FIGHTING FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND PARENTS AND
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO GO TO SCHOOL,